mot service
[Musique]
international bon alors j'arrive à
l'aéroport pas
Giselle je reviens à la maison cou je me
dis non de dieu si ça se trouve est tout
bêtement parti avec Gilbert faire une
promenade tu sais les promenades il font
toujours des promenad
à vélo non pas à
vélo ah la mer mais non
oh ah ben c'est à pied pas à
pied promade promenade comment dit Arom
non oh
pas oh c'est trop bête ça hier c'était
trop bête aujourd'hui ça ne l'est plus
un mot vous manque il vous suffit de
composer le 608 30 30 MSI mot service
international et l'on vous dépanne dans
le quart d'heure on va trouver René je
t'assure qu'on va trouver
tagadaada pas parti pr
calme-toi le mari de la jum Mar ben
c'est son mari sal
tais-toi une promenade une promenade ah
cheval signé
ici
cheval un
cheval des chevaux
MS mot service
international cette fois je fous le camp
Jacqueline dansendu je fous le camp je
me B ah tu sais quoi tant mieux
barre-toi je peux plus supporter
tentends respirer tu comprends je veux
respirer avec toi plus que ça veut dire
me touche pas tu met cur Roger tu sais
quoi Roger tu n'es qu'un Roger tu n'es
qu'un et vas-y d là tu nes qu'un Roger
tu nes qu'un tu nes qu'un Roger tu nes
qu'un Roger Roger tu nes qu'un Roger
Roger Roger tu nes Roger Roger Roger
Roger tu
nes m s i m service international Roger
tu nes qu'un Roger Roger tu nes qu'un
pourri
pourri signz là
merci mot service
international nous par 500 mais par un
PR enfort nous nous
VI 3000 comment
MS mot service internation
n 3000 en
arrive mot service international une
entreprise moderne dans un cadre
d'aujourd'hui un personnel compétent
toujours prêt à intervenir nos hutes et
nos hôesses spécialisés vous présente
maintenant leurs produits livrabl dans
les 10 minutes politique Hian scandale
chionlit chômage majorité ex majorité
liberté égalité nationalisation
déstabilisation attent à la bombe ce
d'alerte culture
Françoise maison de là MJC opéra opéra
comique opéra très comique
socialisme petit mot
Paul bisou poupette chatounet coquine
chérie dernier arrivage turlurette et
rou gros mot Nicole et SAR trou de B bid
couillon chiasse
MSI mot service international MS de jour
comme de
nuit
chérie
chéri tu la sens ma
grosse
gros ma
moustache bien
sû
MS service
international MS mot service
international à partir du 2 juin 82 en
[Musique]
anglais
mot service
internationalice
[Musique]
international